[Music]
well is silver the new must-have
pandemic protection
how does it work and what do consumers
really need to know kirsten joyce
joining us now in the studio
on the silver trend for protection well
denise there are so many masks to choose
from right chances are you found one you
certainly love over the past nine months
however
since wearing a mask will likely still
be necessary for many more months to
come you might want to consider one of
these
a pure silver face shield
sharon whiteley is the founder of true
47 a line of naturally sanitizing face
masks and other protection products
all made of 99.99 pure silver
this is pure ionically plated silver we
tested this against every single gel
spray and disinfected on the market
anyway after a year of research fell in
love with silver and ended up creating
this whole company
around silver that was five years ago
after her own personal health scare she
wanted to enhance other people's lives
through health and wellness grounded in
science
she called the company true 47 47 being
the periodic scientific symbol for
silver
this silver is an amazing antimicrobial
property it's uh
it goes back to 4000 bc it is a natural
element before the advent of antibiotics
in the 40s
it was the antibiotic of the day when
the pandemic hit her company started
branching out with different items
spritzes sprays wipes and wraps and of
course a variety of masks
what's really unusual about our masses i
think we're the only people
making them out of pure what's called
ionically plated silver
it's not nano technology particles which
is coating
of them this is a rip stop nylon
very thin thin core there's literally
bathed in silver it's plated
it will never come off it's uh it's it's
rare
and but it'll last forever you don't
even have to wash them
some even have copper on the outside and
every one of them has silver on the
inside
she calls them the silver lining in
going social
well the masks as described are made of
silver mesh that's this one they're self
sanitizing as we said she said you don't
have to wash them you could put on the
spray
if you do want to wash them you
certainly can put them in a mild soap or
throw them in the washing machine like
she does kirsten joyce reporting live